i get really frustrated with feminists  who claim simultaneously that sex  workers work and that we should like get  rid of all these hang-ups about selling  sex being any different from working in  mcdonald's or you know selling any other  kind of service but then they also get  so sensitive about any perceived section  impropriety in their workplace like  being touched by a boss for instance  like not even in a really aggressive  assaulting way but just getting touched  on the arm or something like that or  being asked out in a context that you  don't really feel comfortable you know  all that kind of me too stuff which is  quite low level if it's really the case  that sex workers work then what is the  problem with being asked by your boss to  give them a [ __ ] it's work it's just  a service it's like being asked to do  over time or make a coffee no one  actually thinks that it's just like  making a coffee